this is gonna sound weird i'm looking
for a guy named duke silver
yeah he goes on in a second
ladies ladies ladies it's just about
that time it's with the jazziest
pleasure that i bring out for you my man
mr duke silva
thank you duane as always it is a thrill
to be here during this witching hour
with you lovely ladies now relax and let
the duke silver trio take you on a
little journey
to yourself
[Music]
bye zuzu
bye
duke silver
my mom has all your albums
i recognize you the day we met
have you told anyone no
good girl
studios down here let's go
hustle people come on
jerry
that's vandalism
i have a problem this happens to be the
studio where a local saxophone legend
named duke silver records his albums
i've heard of him
i heard he makes mature women swoon when
he plays from what i've heard about duke
he's kind of a private guy he doesn't
want his nosy co-workers discussing his
music with him or knowing that he exists
so if you happen to see any memorabilia
laying around kindly and discreetly
discard it you got it duke don't call me
that i dig your griffy tunes man do you
hear me i said i dig your groovy tunes
man
no offense ron but what do you know
about music
hey take a walk
clear your head
i bet it does you some good
where's that saxophone coming from i
don't know
i don't know the first thing about music
is that a new mix sounds way better see
just needed to clear your head
hey you guys who is this this looks just
like
wow that was loud
see you know me pretty well already
but you're about to get to know me even
better
i brought you here because i want to
show you something
that almost no one knows about certainly
not tammy and not even leslie knope
ladies and gentlemen and especially the
ladies put your hands together for the
one the only my man mr duke silva
a mighty fine holiday evening to you all
it might be cold outside
but it's about to get warm all up in my
jazz
i of course duke silver
and i would like to dedicate this first
song
to my duchess
[Music]
you're so lucky
i'm going to kill you
[Music]
gosh this place is packed huh you folks
must really like this guy honey he is
sex on a stick ladies and gentlemen put
your jazzy hands together for my man mr
duke silver
a smooth and silky evening to you all on
nights like this when the cold winds
blow
and the air is awash in the swirling
eddies of our dreams come with me and
find safe haven
in a warm bathtub full of my jazz
[Music]
can i help you maybe i was out of the
jazz club last night scouting bans for
the unity concert and i saw something
very interesting
you have a twin brother
what
i have a twin brother
yes i am duke silver
the only other people you know are tom
and april so please keep it to yourself
are you kidding me you're really good
you're like the saxophone player for the
california racing's good no joke you
know what i'm booking you
for the unity concert absolutely not my
musical career is private if my secret
got out this office would be waist deep
in women's undergarments i'm in charge
of booking the bands for the concert and
i say you're in you're going to play
right after bobby night ranger it's the
night ranger cover band where they only
wear red sweaters it's going to be epic
well how about this unity concert huh
honey
[Applause]
i love this town so much and i'm just so
proud to live here
and we're going to close tonight out
with a tribute
to pawnee's greatest treasure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
once we've all said
goodbye
you take a running leap and you learn
is
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen mr duke silver
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well this is different from what i
expected to find
morning guys good morning leslie
what did you do to the office ron you're
wearing my yoga clothes you're going to
stretch out the elastic we're sorry
[Music]
you